did I go hey Gert okay hmm
chris'll yes where you from where you
grow um I grew up in two different
places like Silent Hill Arkansas and I
grew up in Beaverton Michigan no my
father was I found him when I was three
hanging from her basement rafters but my
mom and I had a stepdad who was 60 years
older than me he was in World War two so
so you did yeah he had mental issues and
they put him in a psych ward and then a
week later he was uh he wasn't supposed
to get out and the doctors let him out
and he took a whole bottle of Librium
I think it was and he hung himself yeah
suicide no from the week before that you
know I don't know I don't really
remember my side you remember pushing
his dead body a little bit so I have
PTSD from that but old are you I was
about they're gonna have I'm 36 now I
mean they never really bothered you know
how was your childhood with your stepdad
you mom um honestly I think I had the
most beautiful childhood anybody could
ever have it was very fortunate I grew
up at least I know 80 acres everywhere
on our farm and you know I had nothing
but nature and animals um both Arkansas
was more prettier that was a rural area
violet Hill Arkansas was like
there was a school a post office a
convenience store and my driveway was
two miles long dirt road and it was it
was so pretty and then yeah well my
little time at 16 my mom had moved in my
stepdad had died and then my mom I was
in this her current husband was just Tom
and the waiting you want he was really
not my friend
and so that was a messy move all so I
couldn't be there anymore so at 16 I
moved out was my kids dad my first two
kids dad and that was quite interesting
he worked out Simon I stayed home all
the other area for kids did you know my
first tour was me and uh my oldest son
was six my daughter was three and then
Levi he still was his dad and family and
then my youngest son it was three and a
half now before he was born two months
early and he is both the father is
daughter which isn't his blood daughter
but pretty much it
so you're living here on the street now
yeah you're right
no no I live in the rats and I live in
like inner birds nests I don't really
want one
it's I can't be City bound like this
really bad I go out to like I think it's
if you know that's what is it I'm not
really even from here in Michigan and me
and my boyfriend came down here but
that's a part yes it's different
what's it like I prefer black it is they
call it airline but I mean I do both but
I don't like that ice it makes me
homesick
I see and I smoke me they call it clear
I know a mess tonight yeah I know no no
I
dumpster drive like the other day I told
the canopy out of a dumpster Ferdinand I
got it like a hundred fifty for that
I've got a convertible thing that was a
hundred fifty or you know you go over to
Walgreens and you see in there and
people will just get any money or I'd um
sells it straight you know where I'll
call my mom mm-hmm and that's once a
month so yeah
okay did you ever talk to your kids I'm
not really my first two kids my mom and
their dad that's a really rough
situation
my first two kids dead I was with him
for 11 years so it's 16 til he's 27 and
those two kids were my life like nobody
helped me that I wasn't there and me my
son
we bonded really good but my mom kind of
took my kids over when I lost my
apartment because I was cooking maths
really bad and they went and she was
like sending me out to do that you know
what I mean so it's been about 10 years
since I seen my first two kids and then
you I know he was in Kalamazoo and I was
running around Kalamazoo and the little
one I don't you know he I adopted mo
it's just hard for me to see him his dad
was just murdered wasn't real pleasure
get us a baseball bat so yeah
so you were in jail for it
I was in Geoscience I took drug court
which in Michigan and Michigan mass as a
felon yeah and I had a mess possession
of meth pop up and that took a while
that one
and before that I had got a possession
amazing yeah and analogs charge so and I
was facing all three of those and a
marijuana charge so I took drug court
which is like an 18-month program and um
well I knew that wasn't gonna work so I
went through the loops with that got
caught and then they took me out drug
court and gave me nine months my stuff
dad died when I was like before I moved
out it was after we moved to my cousin
but he died 97 and then my mom and we
talked that me and my mom are close I
mean she was sleeping with my first kids
yet and I didn't find that out so later
but she's just been really kind of
rotten and she doesn't even let me see
my kid balus yes Bella and then caleb is
with dad but it does see were just it's
hard for me to talk to everyone see you
bud bring my kids down to see I didn't
go to the Christmas party at my aunt's
house you know five miles away and she
couldn't even bring him over to see me
you know so I don't think my daughter
even knows who I am really I mean she
knows who I am but we don't really talk
about it's hard
my mom's just she hurts me a lot
um he's a good guy I guess we're going
through some tough times I've been with
him since G own what about Hannah's is
we had the same birthday as weird and
I'm a few hours earlier um he has a good
guy but he's kinda he's from Kalamazoo
and people from Kalamazoo don't usually
come out their only reason I'm here is
cause I am I never wanted to come to
California um he wanted to get high
under average the lead singer of Red Hot
Chili Peppers or something
sings under the bridge and he wants to
go into that rigidity or something I
don't know and also he was facing some
felony charges so you know I you know I
mean he just got done doing five meters
prison so I got my friend to drive us
out here and drop us off but he was
supposed to be working and stuff you
know you know that guy didn't come
through so we got stuck in the tree
honestly right now I think about Todd's
a lot um it seems like it would just be
a lot easier I just get tired of it I've
been in the street good six years um and
when I see in the street I don't just go
sleep in people's houses I'm not your
average girl I don't mingle with men you
know what I mean um I usually just say
to my partner but if there's any help me
and my boyfriend Blake would like to get
clean together everybody one I feel like
that's the only way that I'm you know as
if somebody's doing it with me it's hard
for me because I mean everybody's been
on I started shooting up drugs when I
was nine or no 12 but I started smoking
weed
I did start shooting cocaine in 12 so
I've been a drug addict for quite a lot
enjoy until your sellers yeah that was
pretty yeah but I was curious yeah well
at 12 my mom you know knows though and
my mom doesn't my mom never really buys
me my purse my Johnson wasn't perfect
but it was very nice I mean I always had
room to run and animals play was but I
never any friends I was very very
isolated um I really didn't have no
friends but at 12 yeah I got on the
internet was meeting guys off the game
and it's full of I I really started
going downhill top and my mom didn't
really care and my stepdad you know so
yeah I started using well it wasn't hard
and I always when I was like older
people when I was in Middle School I was
having in high school or take me out to
go party you know my best friend was in
high school so I cannot we talked about
with older people you know I guess I
didn't really fit in with yeah yeah he
was really weird and and he can't have
moved on and it was uncomfortable
because my mom was like oh you're just
jealous and maybe I was I'm even was all
I had you know besides my grandma and I
don't know he's just as I took over
anyone
he's like you're just jealous because I
spent more time with him and she was
drinking and I was I didn't want to be
there anymore he made me feel really
weird you know they had a boyfriend at
the time that worked and we got her all
but yeah you had me comments all the
time I almost think that and I don't
like the fact my daughter's with them
but I almost think Mimi you know he
would he was mad because I wouldn't you
know acknowledges I don't know he was
just a weird guy all in general I really
don't like the right now he really is
messed up my whole relationship with my
children and my mom she won't even talk
to me on the phone because I Haman you
know I just
he hates me or something I don't know he
he tells my kids all kinds of lies about
me yeah I don't know I really don't like
the guy if he died tomorrow
me I really don't have nothing for that
man I really don't like him at all
actually I haven't been able to go to it
I didn't been able to go home
I didn't step foot on the properties I
just don't need to be my like oh yeah
yeah thank you thank you appreciate it